hallo leute hinzukommen zu dieser runde
skyways zusammen mit peter leys wir
spielen sky bars mal ganz ohne mlg
erfrischend neu neu erfunden schwert
probieren auch nicht erschienen titel zu
schreiben leute es klappt oder nicht und
dann habt ihr so eine ganz klassische
currywurst und ich weiß du bist mlg
neuer schnitt aller ich bin sicher ich
habe was mit dir schneller machen ja mit
dem nachmieter weil ich mich bevor ein
paar kicker kommen so wie ich da passe
ich ganz gewiss auf peterle de ja du
musst aufpassen die fischer rasieren den
chairman table ist wohl noch mal hast du
gold apfel für hertha drei stück habe
ich an zwei stellen kannst ihn
zurückgeben
hast du zwei alter weil ich weiß wie
nötig das ist sag mal hast du dir sagen
hast du ja in der tat habe ich jetzt
hier ist eine anständige
rüstungsaufträgen geworfen wo ich meine
gekracht habe ich idiot
sag mal hast du und überhaupt keine
absicht wirklich grad in dem moment
nämlich geben die level und dann zu
weiteren kommen da einer ist sogar das
wissen wir machen ja mein schwert
verzaubern auf fertigungs modus gibt es
mir völlig verzaubert werbung behälter
pferd einer schon hacks okay yahoo
aber eins ist mal drauf gekommen er
warte aber ich habe auch ganz weitere
kräfte legal nehmen das mit schafen es
einfach ja das anders hätte ich eh nicht
angenommen dankeschön ja gar kein essen
die mitgekommen werden schon relativ
entspannte anfangsphase
sagen dann gehe ich jetzt schon mal
rüber hier muss natürlich auch aufpassen
dass man für ein bisschen die leute
wollen auch zeigten die wollen dass gott
ich habe hier muss ich sagen was von
apple
ich hab kein kein zweiter halt nur
diejenige am anfang hatten also auf
angeln auch bitter ja genau ich mach uns
schnell welche sehr gut ich habe einmal
horst gespielt da wusste ich nicht wie
man eine angel macht und die leute haben
mich so dafür bleibt und ich weiß immer
noch nicht so wirklich aber ich jetzt
herausfinden leute findet heraus was
sogar den bart trägt das okay kam mit
neuer okay wir haben keine bauen sich da
ein vater mein gold appel noch nicht
drauf gehen noch nicht war noch von oben
alles ein
kannst du von oben nicht du hast du das
spiel pickups nein habe ich nicht
brauche ich einfach straight rosinen
sind dann holen wir sie aus kassel aber
immer die ich damit weit aufrücken geht
nicht glaub ich hab sie sind hier drin
ja kannst du eben loch in die wand
machen womit ihm keine pixar ja ich hab
nix mehr
doch nach dass du noch einen ihr warum
bist du ja fix machen dann solltest du
dir ne die ab weil damit damit kannst du
wenn der gruppe 8 tatsächlich hier komm
ich mache jetzt lg nike anna winter in
dem schreiben immer die mittel kommen
anders von bestimmt okay wir dürfen uns
nicht überraschen lassen
er darf so ähnlich hingehen da sind sie
die tat wir dürfen uns nicht überraschen
lassen wo zweiter versuch wir spielen
auf der karte pirate fließt ein bisschen
kleiner deshalb häufig können das wird
schnell durch recken können
ja die ist kein kleiner roman ich hatte
die kleine chips im kreis zu schaffen
ist in die mitte
bestimmt haben müssen sie jetzt so nicht
nur ganz kurz vorbei
aber ich glaube jetzt sucht das
eigentlich schon passen mit dem vertrieb
innovativer schaffen wir niemals mit der
nfl die perfekt zu werfen dass sie nicht
darüber fällt firma doch das schaffen
wir
ok dann versucht mal aber es war schon
vielleicht passen ich bisher gespielt
haben vor allem eins ein legendärer
irgendwie so da sollten jetzt nicht
hingehen passt in die mitte
ich bin verdammt minecraft wird die
ändern mein fell gang verloren ersten
das lager so dumm sich da oben rein zu
werfen
ja es geht oder was wie ich sehe was
geht es geht
was gleich wieder was auch hier wieder
keine blöcke aller hast du ja okay dann
machen wir nämlich jetzt den mlg 3000
bist du denn ganz oben
du bist gestorben
vielleicht sollte es einfach nicht sein
mit uns das ist einfach mist mitfeiern
wir sind halt okay aber keine als peter
wie heißt du fragen der typ der ist
immer da wo man tatsächlich nicht zwei
leute alle server down getötet ist in
alle server wächst das einfach nicht
einfach ich glaube das wasser den
einfach zu blöd ich will geld
zurückerhält
ich glaube damit belassen jetzt einfach
mal ganz einfach zu blöd jetzt wie
scheiße geld zurück mit geld zurück ich
will aber auch helfer geld zurück
natürlich